you had an article about you come out I
think his independent newspaper wasn't
it yes which is an online blog if you
don't know yeah yeah the independent
comment section which is open to all as
became clear when I read this they yeah
they released this article that it
wasn't necessarily about me but it
opened with this person who claimed to
be a new comedian on the circuit well
the subject of the article was as a
comedian working the circuit I am like
something like horrified by regret these
old jokes regressive humor coming back
into comedy
now there's lots of context I mean it's
been symptom dean disproved that he was
actually a comedian lots of lots of
people on my behalf got in touch with
the independent it was way more angry
than I was about it like Stuart Lee and
Al Murray and Tom Rosenthal were all
emailing the independent trying to see
if he was real or NOx they thought it
might be like a spiked inside job but it
did still read like a spiked spoof of a
God in our court but it turns out this
guy isn't a comedian but I at the moment
let's say he's real and the article
opens with him at my show most recent
show and just talk about gender politics
which I've seen yes no compliment there
just purely in facts I have seen it so
he walks out the show after halfway
through and in in the article he says
this is because it's regressive Jim
Davidson style he calls it cause the
show a thinly veiled rape apology which
I totally disagree with there was no
thinness to be sure yes I must just
stress she was obviously most rewarding
this point I've seen the show it's not
what the show is and what I think what I
think I do is I like to take subjects
that people feel very tense about and
are often divided into very facile kind
of infantile binaries and I like
to just explore them and investigate all
areas and angles and I don't try and
land on a specific side I you know I try
and I I sort of take all the arguments
in good faith I think there must be
elements of truth on both sides so the
trying investigate a way of you know
seeing both these things so in this
context it was you know the me to thing
which is obviously is outpouring of rage
about how women haven't had a chance to
have their crimes that can be committed
against them properly processed how do
you balance that with the possibility of
a hashtag ruining a man's livelihood
when it wasn't true
now if you those are but those are two
problems that coexist and it's childish
to pretend that one doesn't and so this
is often what gets you know if you say
you sort of get forced into a corner we
have to say I believe every everyone I
believe all women or you could say oh
it's all bollocks they're all lying and
obviously those are both ridicu have to
find a way of dealing with both problems
but if you you know what's happened here
is that I've sort of tried to articulate
quite a nuanced position and and he said
that just from deviating from this this
point of view I'm not a rape apologist
and the irony is if he'd stayed for the
rest of the show he would have found out
who the real rape apologists in the
comedy industry is as that's who I sort
of name and shame but I probably can't
go into that here as you'll get done for
libel
[Laughter]
but yeah it's it was a strange article
you then went on to go and push this
sort of thing that is not quite often
said nowadays the you know these two
camps in in comedy comedies in the in
the grips of like a struggle for its
soul and on one side you have let's say
of argument the left who believe that
comedy needs to have a social conscience
that as a comedian you are sort of like
an agent actively participating in a
culture you
words are powerful and you could end up
contributing to a culture of oppression
and the kind of totem pole the icon of
this side is people like Hannah Gatsby
who wrote this
I mean arguably the most successful
Edinburgh show of ever sort of a take
down of comedy and from like a you know
a marginalized person's perspective it's
now on Netflix the OP the officers out
of the argument is the free speech is
under threat this is just comedy
political correctness is killing what's
just you know meaningless jokes and this
article was basically from this
perspective pushing me into this camp
welcome i i i don't really think this
culture war exists in the way that a lot
of people like to believe it does i
think it's one that only really exists
online in this kind of endless ping-pong
match of [ __ ] block not to swear yeah
of course
[ __ ] blogs and preachers podcast man
meaningless hot takes but i as someone
who you know works the circuit solo
shows arts festivals i i don't really
see these battles taking place in an
audience and so i sort of that's why i
didn't really want to I was asked to
reply to this article in the independent
shops I was like well no I'm gonna work
for you for free it's really a
refutation from you but I didn't really
want to play this game that they push
you into a corner with you know you then
accepting the terms of their framing
aren't you that yeah there is these two
battles and one has to win and one is
right and one is wrong when I sort of
think that you know you can like
different stuff hmm like me and Hannah
Gatsby have the same agent yeah it's the
same person is responsible for both our
careers in the UK I think if this guy
found that out his brain would
explosions like it's you know it's I'd
love to call it art but it how how is
your cultural taste now informed by your
political van
I don't see that as at all true but do
not think sometimes I mean I've and I
really like your comedy I genuinely do
but I've seen a joke that you do on
stage and in front of a very liberal you
know there is a snowflake crowd and the
moment you say the joke you lose the you
you lost them for a certain period of
time and you could see them tense up and
shut down and it was a joke aimed at
Mediterranean people my girlfriend is
Greek Cypriot she found it hilarious
yeah and all the middle class white
people in the room thought you were a
hate monger well no they didn't you know
what I'm saying well yeah I mean the
point is I do know when I'm losing the
crowd yeah that is deliberate because a
lot of the a lot of stuff is aimed at
people like me precious white liberals
they're just teasing how much they think
about it this is this is I suppose the
thing is that if I was doing these this
jokes you know you know if I was branded
was branding myself as you know free
speech warrior mmm this truth teller
then I would get a crowd that want that
you know people that buy into that sort
of side of the argument but it's not as
fun as when it's in front of a mixed
crowd and that's part of the reason I
didn't want to sort of get into this so
much is that I'm really proud of the
fact that when I do solo shows and the
festivals and stuff
it's an insane mix of people that would
never normally be in the same room you
know you have you know there's old white
fellows in the three-piece suit the
fedora you know proper old Tories bear
sitting next to women with blue hair
you know polyamorous vegan queer
community people and they sort of
project their own things onto what I do
I think because I don't you know I
deliberately don't try and fit into one
of these worldviews that rubbishes the
other but yeah I'll tell your point I I
know that I I actively do try and annoy
a lot of people but it's um you know
that Mediterranean joke the joke is in
the me to thing it's hard to know if
Harvard woman's know if a man is a sex
pest or he is just met a terrain
but that's that's gained right in it's
just about acceptable because it's a
broad enough group it's not really a
distinguished enough but then surely the
counter-argument to someone is that is
that you are being as a white male of
privilege yeah you were being
discriminatory to Mediterranean men you
know you're crossing them always being
you know particularly predatory that is
not fair that is not acceptable
neither is that right and I am offended
okay well it's a joke it's obviously not
true the the untrue nurse of it should
be enough but there is a point of that I
suppose of the far left who would
actually say well yeah but you have a
duty and a responsibility yes but my
point is that it's a very small fringe
of people to actually think that and I
think the sort of the free speech guys
on the right are similarly a sort of
fringe on the right yeah yeah there's
also free speech people who are not
right of course I mean yes but there are
the people that push these I'm using
left and right just as India the people
that push these divides I just I don't
see I see 90 percent of comedy audiences
do not politicize their enjoyment or
lack of it if they find something funny
they laugh if they don't they don't they
find it edgy or close to the bow and
they go oh okay they enjoy making that
noise yeah yeah and if it's a bit
women's girly go there and if it's only
a certain type of person that walks into
a show with a kind of preset I think
this well there's a mutual friend of us
who I'm not going to name on the show
but yeah he was doing a show about men
last year you may know how I'm talking
about and he was doing a preview at a
club that I know and and a woman stood
up in the middle of a show and said
you're a white man you're not allowed to
talk about this and wouldn't leave until
the show was ended yeah that's my point
that this person would exist in that
first III as I see a minority but that
would not have happened 10 years ago as
my point no maybe my number the minority
has got more emboldened on both sides
and that's possibly because both sides
Oh way over perceive the threat of the
other hmm because they have to because
they're reactive narratives you can't
have the we need to clean up comedy sort
of you know you guys will dinosaurs
without the other guys saying were free
speech and you can't have they can't
exist without them because they're both
parasitic they live off the other right
and so they maybe got emboldened and
maybe got louder and maybe they have
more more spirit for a fight but I I
don't I just don't see it as something
that actually exists in the way there is
it's made out to so much online we've
just described as exactly the thing
you're saying doesn't exist which is the
culture war that the two edges becoming
emboldened and then dragging other
people in that is the cultural right
it's it's it's the there are small
minorities that are sucking you in yeah
well they're sucking everybody in
because yeah our conversations in
society about privilege about
discrimination about you know something
we'll go on to talk about which is the
dude Acula another peer you've actually
been prosecuted for saying things which
were a joke like your defense of your
joke about mediterranean people and i
don't be offended by that because i'm a
quarter greek right yeah your defense is
that's a joke and it's obviously not
true but if you have something like his
case where the judge said the prosecutor
and the judge said context doesn't
matter intent doesn't matter then you
get into a point where if you say
something on stage and someone chooses
to take it literally and you say a lot
of stuff that can be misinterpreted that
way yes sure right then you end up in a
position where you can be criminalized
so i guess what i'm saying is if you say
there's no culture well i think what
you're saying is there's no culture war
in broader society right in in them in
the mainstream of society which i can
kind of agree with to some extent yeah
but i feel the only reason that that's
true is that this way of thinking hasn't
seeped into that far enter but it will
because yeah universities these people
are being indoctrinated so yeah so so
you see it as a precedent to a kind of
dystopia yeah whenever i and sometimes I
do but I'm then I then go off Twitter
for a week
and I and I just do gigs no you know
Friday Saturday night clubs and these
these hot takes don't exist people enjoy
it or they don't enjoy it and you know
16% of the UK are on Twitter I mean just
just think about how small
that's comedians media people
politicians journalists and [ __ ]
lunatic
[Music]